i think i've told you
many times how much i love edge of
tomorrow just
love that movie do you prefer people
calling it edge of tomorrow
or live die repeat live dive repeat i
hated the edge of tomorrow title
um i fought warner brothers on it um
and uh they insisted um and
and i would i i just think it's it's the
wrong title for the movie and i
still hoping that the film gets fully
rebranded
um um because you know these films live
forever in libraries
completely one of the that's one of
those films though that every time
i i say to someone i'm going to talk to
emily blunt or tom cruise or even you
everyone asks um what's going on with a
sequel do you think a sequel could
happen and i believe you guys have an
idea
or possibly a script um do you think a
sequel can actually happen
um it could it's a very high bar
you know because we're we we really that
was a really challenging film to go make
i mean time travel is
is um
uh time tr you know
time travel really when you when you try
to develop a movie set in a world with
time travel you pretty quickly discover
that humans are never going to travel
through time because there's so many
paradoxes
that you can hardly get through a
screenplay um
i mean it's a point where at some point
during the development of the screenplay
of the screenplay the first film uh
warner brothers said to me like does he
need to travel through time
maybe he could just battle aliens and i
was like well you want me to make this
movie he does because
i'm not actually interested in the
aliens i'm interested in the in the
repeating the day part
um and so uh
um and you know i have always i've
always been interested in the idea
of of of a sequel being
more character driven than the first
film
and uh because that's not how things are
normally done
and so that's that is the sort of uh
that has been my approach in terms of
developing a sequel it's like you
uh um and because tom cruise emily blunt
are such
phenomenal actors i get sometimes you
know you the sequel just has to have
more firepower because
you know but are you know more
explosions but are our
you know you're just not gonna get you
know
no no visual effect is gonna top what
you can get
with a great scene written
you know a great scene performed by tom
cruise and emily blonde
well that's the thing a lot of people
forget if action doesn't matter if you
don't care about the characters
you know and their their performances
work
what drives that film um do you think
with each with hbo max is it easier to
maybe
get the financing or the the ability to
move forward on it because they're
looking for product
they're looking for films or is it one
of these things that it's sort of tied
up on the script
and tom's availability and emily's
availability
it's one of these things where if tom
emily and i were like
we're ready to pull the trigger on this
script like it's
it's tom cruise and emily blunt like the
film gets made
i mean that's pretty much how hollywood
works it's the
the the stars of the gatekeepers if you
can get tom cruise and emily blunt to
commit to a movie
movie's gonna happen can i do my last
question on
on this um how far along are you on a
seat on a script
is there something that you guys are
like really happy with or is it still
just not there yet
it's not there yet but by the way that's
not really an impediment because you
know
for for lived i repeat the script wasn't
there when we started shooting
in fact the the tom and i sort of often
laugh about this that
you know during prep on that movie
we would say to ourselves there's
nothing like a looming start date for
the shoot
to put pressure down to get the script
right
and then while we were shooting the
movie we were saying to ourselves
there's nothing like a looming rap day
to really put pressure down on on
getting the script done
right and then while we're editing the
movie we're like
there's nothing like a looming release
date to force you to get the script
right
i mean these are really big amount
you know it's a big imaginative movie
it's it's not
it's not some like lockdown where you
know it's it's one writer's singular
vision and
and you know you you want to shoot that
exact story with that intimacy
it's it's the canvas is just so much
bigger than any one person
are you then a little bit surprised at
how much people love the movie
and how well it turned out considering
you didn't have a finished script when
you started shooting
no in a way i was sort of more
disappointed that people it took people
time to find it
you know that it was and i think it's
because warner brothers forced the wrong
title on the movie i've had that
experience you know throughout my career
where i've had movies that i'm
incredibly proud of and then
they don't like born identity didn't
really perform when it first opened
but it eventually found an audience
yeah i heard that one did pretty well
but it's you know you need to but
at the time you know they it stung when
born identity opened
it it stung when when uh engine tomorrow
lived that repeat open it stung you know
but it's but i i try to not have it uh
i i i try to be zed and just say well
i'm re i'm
better than that i am proud of the movie
like that that should be the most
important thing but
you know probably need some more therapy
before
i can fully you know do that